so tell us what we have here your well
we've got our friendly reminders
um masks are required we have our little
friendly reminders from the health
department
and notifications to our dining capacity
so people understand
it's not the number of chairs and tables
in the room it's the number of people i
can allow
in in the building for a safe dining
experience so let's go inside and tell
us what
safety masters you're taking here at
table 34.
well we're trying to keep uh sanitizer
available for all of our guests
and we have a little area here where you
can sanitize your hands
before you enter the dining room if you
forget your mask
we provide them for you we have a little
box here with masks just in case you
left it in the car
and you know we want to make it as easy
as possible and as friendly as possible
how huge are you with spacing tables
well we've got everything spaced
six feet apart and then what happens is
since our
dining capacity is so limited we'll try
and leave some blank tables
in the mix especially the traffic areas
as you can see we've
left a couple empty there in the main
traffic areas
that way you feel more comfortable as a
diner you're not so close to everybody
so we've got it as spaced out as we can
and
at limited capacity it makes it it makes
it okay but we've gotta
we've gotta look out for everyone's
safety amen
so obviously you guys you encourage a
lot of people to come
dine in but aside from takeout because a
lot of people are also getting take out
yes what can the community do to help
you guys strive
during this 10 minutes well like i
mentioned earlier you know midweek
dining
helps out a lot if you if you're
thinking about us or any other
restaurant
think about during the middle of the
week as well not just friday and
saturday
and then takeouts always available and
you know we love to accommodate our
guests in any way we can and as long as
as long as you're thinking of us we
couldn't be happier
under the 25 capacity would you say that
you're still struggling
or you know you've taken other messages
you told me about the people
yeah i mean 25 is definitely a big
hurdle
um however if we can utilize our
seating capacity correctly and
people have to make a reservation now so
we can manipulate it a little better and
make it work
um it is more difficult at 25 but
we're very hopeful that things are going
to loosen up here in the near future
and we can at least get back to maybe a
50 capacity
and that would definitely be a nice nice
shot in the arm that we all need
shot in the air thank you so much for
your time